you you use this every day every day
they're not for casual listening
they're for serious listening to your
favorite artists last saturday my wife
went out i understand she came home she
told me she was home for two hours i
didn't notice
because i'm sitting there listening to
music right it's going to involve you
completely or your wife is in the house
you know i don't even know if i go by
two chains two chains i'm
over the top sometimes wow and right now
we're going to check out the most
expensive
[ __ ] it's definitely crazy
what up what up it's your player partner
2 change checking in
most expensive is [ __ ] and today we're
going to talk about headphones
and no disrespect to any other
headphones out there but these are the
most expensive
sennheiser orpheus he90 sound like some
real star trek [ __ ]
and my homie larry almost one of 300
let's check it out
what you got going on here what's up
with the masterpiece we got headphones
we got headphones like you have
never heard before they are amazing so
in 1991
german company sennheiser said we're
gonna make the world's best headphones
so they did
and they called it orpheus after the
greek god now it's two pieces right
these are the headphones over here these
are the things you actually wear and
when you put them on
they don't weigh anything those are not
heavy not heavy though they look bulky
they're from the 90s 90s was a more
bulky trend that's what i feel so that
those are not heavy they look like they
could be they look like they're wood
they look bulky but i'll tell you what
is big the sound is big
they got to be plugged into the mate
unit so called amp stereo amplifier
which is there so it's an amp
it's an amp just for the headphones
tubes take a little time to warm up
there's an ignition switch it's like a
fine car
seriously there's no i can't get this he
has a key on here
you have to really crank it yeah yeah
you kind of get like a car
the amount of time it takes for a sphere
of ice
to just melt enough into a glass of
single malt scotch
is exactly the time it takes for the
tubes to warm up it is the
closest you can be to listening to a
live
session i do music now i know you've
kind of i've heard that and we've got
your music loaded
up time to listen right now time to
listen give you a little tingly feeling
on the inside
that's me it is i sound good you do
i drink red [ __ ] red bulls
give me wings but i already
they are actually lighter than they look
they actually like and they feel good
yeah
yeah did you get this in 91 or or was it
after 90. no i got it
totally afterwards i got it like 2007.
when they were originally put out by
sennheiser the list price was i think
about 12
800 just under 13. on ebay they
stabilized around 20 or 21 000
until the japanese collectors came in
the market and now they're back over 30
000.
i paid 6. pay 6 000 i got the bargain of
the year man
i still had to tell my wife i'm excited
about you just giving me the opportunity
to hear me
myself live but it was it was kind of
funny because it wasn't live but it
sounded alive
but i'm here live so it was just a
little mix-up but we need y'all to get
back you're a little too close
get back get back get back admire this
you have to crank it
you have to drink this with scotch you
have to have a wife that loves you
yes and i do yeah in order to buy this
right here
thank you cool man very cool great to
meet you silent man for sure
i think my music sounds good anywhere
they definitely sounded good in the
orpheus he90s
the guy larry really loves music to me
it seems like he loves life
but to buy for six thousand and then be
worth thirty thousand
i'm not mad at that at all i called that
a flip
but do you think it's worth it leave a
comment subscribe to the gq
channel for more most expensive [ __ ]
[Music]